I don't think the market per se failed I
think that government policies create
market distortions ie too much money
with the Federal Reserve the allocation
the housing there was one factor that
created an odd market failure and that
was fair value accounting fair value
accounting is supposed to be a good
thing because it's marked to market but
in a in a panic situation the market is
not functioning it's not it's not a
market failure it's just the nature of
panics and that created distortions and
I'll give you a simple way that that
happened let's say there was a mortgage
bond in the market that that it had
originally been 100 million dollars but
because of mortgages not being paid
under the bond and people that weren't
expected to pay in the future
economically that mortgage was worth 80
million dollars and that's what it
should have sold for but because of the
panic the only buyers were deep
discounters that would only pay 50
million dollars for it now that had big
implications because under this fair
value accounting the financial
institution instead of marking the
mortgage down 20 by 20 million dollars
had to mark it down 50 million dollars
financial institutions banks or leverage
will just use an easy number 10 to 1 so
instead of destroying two hundred
million dollars worth of lending
capacity which the loss of 20 million
dollars in capital would do it destroyed
five hundred million dollars in lending
capacity I 50 times 10 instead of 20
times 10 because of the counting system
but here's why the market didn't work
was wide in the market correct that
there are people like BB&T that had
plenty of money we saw that bottles
worth 80 million dollars we could buy it
for 50 if we went in and started buying
and everybody else like us had money
started buying the price would have
gotten certainly close up to the 80
million but we wouldn't buy because we
couldn't take the accounting risk
because even though we knew the bond was
worth 80 million dollars we weren't
going to buy it even for 50 min because
we didn't know that next quarter under
this panicky market it would only be a
fair market value quote would only be 40
million because everybody would be
scared and we'd have to take a markdown
so fair value accounting created a
market distortion that never would have
exists
in a free market I would just point out
that the SEC makes the accounting rules
in the u.s. we do not have a private
based accounting system I don't know of
any big firm that runs their internal
operations based on GAAP accounting I
don't know of any hedge fund that runs
their operations based on GAAP
accounting and so the SEC ironically
through the control of the accounting
system created in a market distortion
that I do not believe would have existed
in a pure in a pure free market
I don't believe so I mean I think that
government intervention in the long term
almost always creates poor economic
allocation processes you can make some
arguments in the middle of a painting
the government inefficient helps you in
the short term but the long-term price
for government interference is very high
let's face it the United States faces
some really significant long-term
economic challenges however we feel I
think the economy's in some kind of
recovery I think are most likely
intermediate a scenario is kind of a
stagflation environment but not really
worried about the US twenty to
twenty-five years down the road we got
huge deficit Social Security he's
deficit in Medicare we got trillion
dollar plus operating deficits a
dysfunctional foreign policy we got a
big problem with the demographics with
the retiring baby boomers we got a fail
K through 12 education system you can
paint a very scary fixture 25 years down
the road if we don't if we don't provide
the discipline that's that's necessary
and what that means is not more
government regulation but a return to
what made America great in the first
place individual rights free markets
entrepreneurship increases in
productivity you can't print your way
out of problems if you could symbolic be
doing great right somebody gave me a
trillion dollars in Bali whatever it is
bill the other day and said it was worth
five cents you have to produce your way
and we need to create the kind of
environment where productive people are
encouraged to be taped rational risks
and grow their businesses and we haven't
been doing that so that's our real
problem not market failure
I think the long-term interim
implications are very detrimental if you
want to really think about what happened
in the housing crisis it was a
government policy through Freddie Mac
and Fannie Mae and affordable housing
policies for the caller Community
Reinvestment Act etc that created a
massive misallocation of credit if the
government gets into allocating credit
over time it will make sure we aren't as
productive as we should be so the
government regulation is usually in the
end look like credit allocations usually
to those that are politically favored at
the expense of making sure credit is
allocated to the most productive
segments in the economy so I think
government regulation in the long term
is almost always destructive